Speaker 1: The failed former president Donald
Trump has resurfaced and he appeared on a
program where, you know that phrase, if a
tree falls in the woods and nobody hears it,
does the tree really does it make a noise? It's
something like that. Anyway, he appeared on
something called The Great America Show, hosted
by Lou Dobbs. You might remember Lou Dobbs
from CNN previously, and I think he was on Fox
at one point. I don't know what this show is, but
if you have a show that nobody knows about and
nobody watches, does it really exist then? I don't
know the answer to that. But Trump is as unhinged
and incoherent as ever. I challenge you spot the
number of lies in just this first short clip.
Speaker 2: Well, we wouldn't have inflation.
We wouldn't have the problems that we have.
We'd have an economy that would be roaring.
We'd have $2 gasoline or less.
Speaker 1: Okay. So Trump says if he
were president, we wouldn't have an inflation
and gas would be under two bucks a gallon and
the inflation would be and the economy would be
roaring. Now, think that through. Does anyone
believe outside of this completely deranged MAGA
world, that if Trump were president, every country
would see inflation and high gas prices? Except
for the United States. Somehow, in his infinite
genius and big a brain, Donald Trump would be be
able to do something to make the United States
the one country that doesn't experience the global
inflation that we've seen and doesn't experience
the global increase in gas prices that we have
seen. It doesn't make any sense. The really funny
thing is, Trump says, If I were president, the
economy would be roaring by basically every every
metric. The economy is doing great right now. I
am not diminishing or devaluing the real struggles
that exist in the American economy. Poverty,
hunger, wage. Of course that nothing has changed.
By every major indicator, however, the economy is
very strong. Gas prices down. Inflation down. Job
creation doubled expectations in July, the
most recent month for which we have data.
Stock market is choppy the last few days,
but but significantly stabilized and a great
month in July. And overall looking very good.
Although, you know, I could give you the full
list. We've looked at the four. So if Trump were
president, the economy would be roaring. If Trump
were president and the economy were exactly as it
is today. Trump would claim it's the best economy
in the history of the United States, frankly.
Speaker 2: And we would be dominant in energy.
We wouldn't only be energy independence
like we were. We would be by this time
dominant. We would be the dominant energy force.
Speaker 1: Now, understand that Trump has had to
shift his story on that a little bit. Trump used
to say under me we were energy independent and
we no longer are under Joe Biden. The numbers
are now so readily available and so present,
and they've been repeated so many times. We
actually are just as independent as we were
under Trump. Currently on fossil fuels, of
course. And so Trump has had to shift to say
we would have gone from independent to dominant.
Speaker 2: It's just a disaster. The windmills
are destroying you. Take a look at
destroying our beautiful open spaces
and our plains and our valleys, and you just
look at what's happening to the country now.
Speaker 1: Does Trump say when Trump says that
the windmills are destroying planes, I assume he
doesn't mean airplanes. I assume he means like
the great planes or whatever. And of course,
they're doing no such thing. And we've talked a
lot about, yes, wind power has a carbon footprint
and wind power also has, you know, like
many forms of energy. You also have things
you then have to dispose of, like the wind farm
blades, etc.. But wind power is is a great thing.
Speaker 2: Is windmills that are so horrible. They
are all made in China and Germany, by the way, but
they're all made outside of the United States.
It's a shame what's happened to our country,
and it truly is. It's a country that's
failing. It's a country in decline. And
it's very sad to watch. And then they weaponize.
They weaponize at a level that nobody's ever seen
before. They go after political opponents
at a level that nobody's ever seen before.
Speaker 1: Right. I mean, listen, Trump quite
literally attacked the media, ridiculed people's
appearance, was a dystopian authoritarian
wannabe. But it's Democrats now who are doing
things to their political enemies in a way that
we've never seen before. That's completely and
totally absurd. Trump then continuing on
this extraordinarily bizarre program, and
he seems to be sort of grasping at what he
believes are relevant straws when in reality they
very much are not. Continue to listen to this.
Speaker 2: I did nothing wrong, and it's the
exact same thing here. We were essentially
attacked. We were broken into. They opened
up safes. They brought safe crackers that.
Speaker 1: Now understand this was a legal
search warrant. The search warrant listed the
safe. They're allowed to look in the places
delineated in the search warrant. This is another
narrative that only will work on people who either
aren't paying attention or are a little bit dim.
This was an illegal thing that took place. This
was essentially a burglary of Mar a Lago. There
was a search warrant. There was an affidavit.
The FBI director signed off on this. The attorney
general signed off on this. A judge signed off on
it. They gave Trump every opportunity, every
opportunity to prevent this. It was completely
and perfectly legal. But they want to convince
people it was some kind of strong arm burglary.
Speaker 2: They brought many, many FBI agents
in. Yeah. All right. Before the midterms and all,
when I have the best poll numbers I've ever
had, this is a political attack on our country.
Speaker 1: Now, I don't know what poll
numbers he's talking about, but I've not
been able to find evidence of what he's saying.
Speaker 2: And it's a disgrace. And the people
understand it. The people understand it. And they
could have come in and they could have talked to
us and they could have taken whatever they needed.
Speaker 1: And they did understand that this is
another part of the story. One part of the story
is this was essentially a burglary. These were
thugs who came in and cracked my safe. It
was a home invasion. The other part of it,
of course, is they could have just asked me
for what they wanted. And now we have the
paper trail on that as well. They did ask
numerous times and in fact, Trump lawyers,
we still don't know whether the Trump lawyers
believed it when they said it or not. But Trump
lawyers said, we've turned everything over. We've
we've turned it all over when indeed they had not.
Trump was given every opportunity to prevent this.
Speaker 2: But instead they raided it. They took
my passports. They they took things
that they should have never taken with
that are privileged. And it's
a disgrace to our country. It
really is. It's just and it just
never ends. It's the same people,
the same leaks, the same they leak to the same
places, the same people doing the leaking. It's a
disgrace. It's a disgrace. Our country is a wreck.
Speaker 1: Yep. So essentially nothing true there.
And continuing to pull this. I'm a victim. I'm
a victim. I'm a victim. I'm a victim. Now that
is not going to work in court. If it gets to
that point, it is no longer going to be a valid
excuse in the court of public opinion. It has
worked quite well. I mean, you go to events,
the standouts in Florida and other places where
Trumpists are interviewed and they have fallen for
the Trumps, really the victim. Eric Trump goes on
Fox News and speaks in places where the nobody's
been treated as poorly as we've been treated,
but that's not going to work in court. So that's
Trump on The Great America Show with Lou Dobbs.
Let's take a look at the truth social stuff next.